uhoh come back here I'll cover you I am
almost dead all right you're going to
have to crawl to me but I'll make sure
no Stomps on you where are you there you
are you said you make
sure hey everybody Gears of War for is
out soon so I'm joined by Lucy James Tom
Hussein in our very ghetto setup ignore
the setup set doesn't matter what
matters is we're going to play some
horde mode players are fine we're going
to try and get as far as we can I going
to complete it today one waves 1 to 50
yeah sure why not watch me do it I
reckon we die in the first Boss Wave no
we'll be fine that's the most
unconvincing I'm not great so um I'm the
best that's the energy I want that's the
energy I want carries us right let's get
started I am the best at Unreal
Tournament all right let's set up and
try not to embarrass ourselves who we
got I'm promising nothing my name is
marus I've done this before green gun
which what talking as if you were really
Marcus yeah this how Marcus sounds right
what class you T I'm what they call a
soul deer Soul deer Soul deer all right
well come on big man Soldier help me
with this if you need my help you look
like you're doing pretty well though on
your own Lu I'm just going to go and
rest in these amongst these trees what
class are you Lucy so I'm tomorrow Ana
an you are Ana um and my class is
engineer so you're going to repair
everything for us make sure nothing
breaks yeah and I'm the sniper I hit
head shot put it down put down put it
down put it down all right so we need to
collect all the energy we get from
killing locust swarm whatever you want
to call them oh God I put it down the
wrong way and then we use that energy to
buy turrets and defenses and then we use
those defenses to help us
win wait why can't I mount this you know
child I defeated the locus once before
obviously not cuz look look where we are
now hey did half a job let me tell you
about the time me and get out my hey
stop running away from me listen Okay
old man no one wants to hear your War
Stories robots are coming oh yes here's
one the BG's are here which one come
here one of them's dead right so two of
them are dead two of them are dead W I
just shot a third one oh I think Barry's
the only one left I'm going to kick this
ball
why is everyone taking if anyone gets
down in the first wave have to
immediately give up their COG
Tags sweet sweet where are you guys
we're off to the
left I'm on your
side uh it's about to be a party in
here Easy Action I mean it's it was wave
one but easy EAS GG easy get the loot we
need that
loot only got two kills but that's
okay should get some
SI stranger stranger strange
danger we got these air drops as well
check what's in
there Marcus that's I'm talking about
the robot was dead and he still kicked
it in the go oo incendiary grenades
there's more in here get you incendiary
grenades here where there's loads of
Drop shots as
well that's what I call my poops
incendiary
grenades you said drop shot both of
those would work I drop shot my
incendiary grenades come get come get
your items before the despawn items here
come get your armor get your
items carrying 1,500 uh ah someone
shooting me in the ass there we
go I'm coming for you
now loads of power oh dear me
S oh dear me accient turned into Mrs
downfire I watched Mrs downfire play K
of War something's behind me on you
go shot him in the butt there's a
guardian where is it above
me all right well I'm out
of oh wow good I'm good swears is it
dead yet Uh something's dead it is dead
where are we at oh [__] I got your back
to
uhoh come back here I'll cover you I am
almost dead all right you're going to
have to crawl to me but I'll make sure
no one Stomps on you where are you there
you are you said you make sure no one
Stomps on you he just
detonated exploded it's right I picked
up your dog tags which apparently have
like a portion of your DNA in yeah I
have dribbled all over those dog
tags my
goodness oh
dear
filth what I said oh dear no the locus
said filth why I back I've only got one
um yeah there's uh like guys around
here the truck oh no luy yeah I know
this is um this a bad situation this is
bad for
me ow Charlie oh no I'm
down Mr Overkill Mr Overkill
sir sir yes sir got you thank
you I love how this gun sounds it's got
the same reload uh reload sound as the
M1 grand there got my DNA in your hand I
thought I well never mind I thought I
resed you but I think I just walked to
the thing and forgot I like how despite
you dying you still got more points than
me to be honest that I probably F most
of that round just sort of running about
taking the
scenery what's
happening oh my grenad are gone oh man I
had to drop my shotgun for
that yink hey I was considering picking
that back up well consider I was
considering have we got enough money to
get a man T how much energy we got we
got enough money to buy me a new shotgun
no no look I'm carrying 700 up Tam I've
got I've got this for you this is your
gift oh thank you so much Dave that's
for you that is enjoy love it's use it
all once I need some milk
ammo help me okay hey check out my new
gun
guys like And
subscribe to my gun to my gun
no oh God [__] what's happening to my
aim just jammed my gun as
well that sound very
good a you son of a [__] son of a [__]
is probably like my favorite I
swear I can't land these shots what's
happened to me over the past 20 minutes
all right there's L go nice all
right there's a one of the BS is coming
to you it's the big one one with a big
gun coming to us oh God yeah he's right
there oh there's a
sentinel senel yeah
ah somehow Lucy and I made the exact
same
sound I got had
grenades oh God we got pouncer over here
oh dear we should run to Tam and let
shoot big gun sorry Lucy we treats Tam
he's got the big
g go go go oh there's another pouncer
over here yeah who that oh dang why did
you sound like a blue Peter presenter
when you said that ah help me help
me oh there another one com hang on I'm
just going to repair your
turret there you go that grenade there
oh help me okay we're good we're good my
days the sneaky enemy used that as an
opportunity to get close
though see that head shot you like that
t that was pretty good what were that
came from
oh we're g where you going where you
going Fu get out
here
out all right repair and reload Rave
seven we got this Rave seven all right
Rave seven you see my tar needs a
manicure
pedicure think of another all it think
of another Beauty I thought you meant
like think of another way to treat your
nails done it needs his eyelashes curled
no tinted it wants its hair died pink
pink that's
difficult also it wants a boob
job
same I think the bonus objective is to
get seven kills with that turret so as
long as it's got ammo in it be
Gucci I can get seven kills with this
turret you better watch me get six and a
half six and a half six and an
assist here they come here they come
there's a big dud
isn't that
big there over he's scared of me he
knows what's about to happen hey hey hey
hey where you going where you going see
you sick of me all right William Shatner
right they're just running towards you
guys oh wow there is like nothing over
here oh from this guy hey that's right
he's very
dead hello this guy's just staring at me
all right they seem to be coming from
your side so if you need to
should we retre over to T to try and
feed him some turret kills they're
coming over here
now boom bo we should really be letting
Tam get these I'll take let's take care
of the guys on the
right all
right
boom
head so
satisfying careful there's a p and he's
out of my field sish good time you need
two
more poun is down all right you got you
got plenty more coming that
way oh God hello Tam look to me look to
me look to me to your right to your
right to your
right [__] oh he's out of he's out of my
view help me I'm tapping the F
nice come here come here you f [__]
nice all right I need
some right there's another one guy
coming down the middle Tam he's all
[Applause]
yours is he not dead
yety Lucy come back let let time grab
that kill there we
go what about this guy kick him there we
go now we're cooking with
gas
a to don't get him a
sorry to torture him don't that's you
know cruel D he's
lo I need some hot turret action there w
we got this I've got fixed got this damn
I'm carrying nearly like two grand yeah
same I've got like 2.7 let's Bank this
this is like the weakest link I'm going
to buy this sentry gun Bank oh I can't
afford to a I've made an
error uh let's put it like here maybe
maybe I got some more shot grenades if
you um if you equip the grenade then
melee the ground you'll make a trap
ooh so all those shot grenades might be
a good
idea means I'll be stunned and to be
able to shoot
them
enemies frag grenades here as well there
there's there's a bucket load of
grenades next to Tam so okay it's a
crate load actually let's uh we don't
have to be stingy With
Grenades oh that one had no
skin no
skin oh big dude there you
go I'm worried about the right hand side
man I've got you don't you
worry fix the uh getting head shots like
it's going out of
fashion boom yeah knee shots are like
the NB black new shots new black oh you
jinxed me missed that
one come on poke your head out poke your
head out how dare you I double dare yet
[__] I drop shot I got drop shoted wait
there I got you you stay on the gun oh
[__] oh
Lord
great well fine okay Lucy's dead yeah I
died the ghost of Lucy James thank you
it's like um that movie
where um it's like husband and wife and
they think they're going to be in some
kind of like Avalanche Mr Mrs Smith no
and the husband like runs away and
totally just leaves the uh the wife but
it turns out that they are aren't
actually in trouble at all and then they
have to deal with s terrible movie no
they deal with the fact that like the
husband instead of risking his life to
save his wife she that sounds like a
Sandra bullet movie I mean he's not
wrong who starred in that I don't know I
heard about it on a podcast
Lu see my turet sorry repair the other
one as well ammunition I think it's
pretty low uh you turet
ow ah oh watch it ouch that really hurt
Lucy repair the Sentry I'm trying Lucy
go I'm repairing
to my I'm good I'm good it's fine it's
not fine also I'm out of um some someone
needs to pick up some power cuz I'm out
I can't oh God getting rushed what is
this guy doing what you doing
e are you good you good what they thing
in the end I used my point blank boom
shot on
him all right there a risky strap paid
off
though okay all right wave 10 Boss Wave
there's a there's a crap ton of um hang
on yeah let's let's grab you repair me
and Sam will grab okay what's the gar
all money C en
en
energy there's Tor bows and stuff as
well we need those I need more all right
I'll bring some Marcus Buck back you I'm
calling him Marcus Buck Marcus it's not
a terrible name fun Buck Phoenix one bu
I don't give about this that's very I'm
picking up a risky buzz
kill I'm so slow now that was a loud
noise it sounds like some sort of Boss
scared already
this is wave oh God okay help me help me
help me help me which is traditionally
where the boss waves come
in their ter I can't see a boss oh he'll
be here oh I found it I found it oh
there he is okay come on
over uh all right I'm leaving this
Goodbye Oh my God what wow did he just
breathe
fire I'm down Lucy Lucy Lucy did you
roll away why did you roll away I'll
draw his fire I'll draw his fire I'll
draw his
fire oh God he looks like he's coming
for me help
me shoot in the belly
I'm
tooot oh God we need to shoot the other
things as well we're going to get
swarmed by the Swarm oh we're good we
Gucci dang can you repair the sentry gun
it's BR
in either someone's vaping next to it or
it's
broken I could do with some ammo as well
if you got some get
[__] okay bad day should have stayed
behind the car bullets oh
JK oops all right we've got a load of
regular Locus but after thinking killing
that snatcher we should be Gucci SN
where is Gucci come from like this is is
this new the third use of Gucci yeah and
I'm like it's not new get on board with
it except it
good that ain't new
girl oh God kicking this guy's ass get
out of my house get out of my swamp 10
waves right how far how deep can we go
how deep can we
go I think we can get to about 12 or 13
12 or
the health doubles now though what oh
they have double
Health woohoo wave 18 wave 20 is coming
up soon oh don't remind me I mean in our
practice run that didn't happen we
couldn't wave 10 I think we got to wave
three on that
one all right get the loot look at this
Beauty look at
this got some good times right okay you
are we putting all our fabricator
currency just into repairing stuff now
apparently
like it takes a lot to uh repair stuff
I've got 3K on the fabricator sound like
a
toilet
reloaded I'm stuck
enjoy in the
destroyed such
potential guys I think I want to adopt
the third turret all right we work wek
more if you save up your pocket money
you can get one I think I could really
love it I'll take it for walks and I'll
feed it and I'll clean up after it clean
up after it and I'll put a ribbon around
its neck you repair it and give it ammo
yep oh they're getting Brave now they're
using chainsaws oh heavens Heavens
crisps clear put so much bullets so much
bullets so much bullets oh wait what
shoot me from here something behind us
no no it's this guy this crack shot over
here dead
shot man I I used an entire muler only
got one
kill oh [__] [__] wow where did come
from help me run back run back run back
Crawling Back somebody needs to get me
up before this Locus ruins where oh no
turrets take care of it turrets please
just come and come and where are you
where are you where are you to right
right there you go got one who did I get
watch out there's a boomer here he's run
a skir I love light
SK there's a heilo
here there we
go how the turrets doing how my boys
they're looking fun I buy the turrets
Tam makes the most out of them and Lucy
repairs them so basically I'm mom you
are the mom you're mom you're the dad
and tomor is the kid I'm the cool Uncle
no you're not creepy Uncle he a kid how
you doing boys stop this ow help
me help me where are you where are you
I'm sorry look where I am I was
repairing repair the
human first of all don't appreciate that
t you're not my mom just my wife imagine
ter
oh nice I'll go over there there good
squishing I'm getting some stuff for my
repairs
ah oh what drop for
me Heavens crisps oh no why you saying
crisps oh was listening to a new podcast
ref funny and he says crisp and it
is oh why have I gone over this barrier
I think that Locus just made a Naruto
reference what did he say not everything
is a Naruto reference I'm pretty sure he
said tun he definitely didn't maybe he
just said ouch in his
language no can we not kill that one
he's in a F sorry why Focus
fire I got oh wow what's going on here
oh Party in the
USA don't understand Lucy's war
cries oh look at this guy over here
watch your right watch your
right oh help me he's dead what's you
doing did you just try P you I think so
wasting time oh my ear
hurts after that l I am so covered in
blood like a strawberry all right wave
20s we haven't gone down we haven't lost
a wave in 10 waves this is look how
Bloody I am I'm going to go collect some
quick get some Marcus
Buck ammo my long repair my
tets one box deposited takes so long to
get over this side of the map let see I
need ammo
well if you need ammo we're not going to
be able to buy a third turret in time
you realize if one like swarm kill comes
against these three turrets they're just
going to get crushed swarmak swarmak oh
no hang on it's 20 Oh I thought we had
an extra I thought we had more time this
is
it come not push sh up that was a tasty
shot what's the boss what boss we
got
[__] oh it looks big
thanks it's a
carrier hey don't believe the
rumors what the hell carrier the carrier
when it opens when it opens its chest
shoot its chest
okay there's a thing stuck on this
car oh my God why haven't you died
nobody no there we go got to be kidding
oh [__] you got to be kidding me why can
I not switch weapons when I've
jammed oh God yeah time watch out help
me on the right help me on the right
help me on the right help me on the
right oh come in come in just run past
that guy yes got you thank you oh those
turrets are not looking
good hey don't underestimate our turrets
we're good repair that [__] reparent oh
God yeah your turret's fine Bill's not
oh God on the right on the right on the
right quick prior fire they're getting
drop shoted oh
[__] ammo ammo ammo this is going
sideways real fast it's raining sideways
kick
him oh god I've got grenades I'm
throwing with my turrets with my no no
okay well someone's alive okay we're all
good okay help me we need to retreat
Retreat to the other side of the map
Retreat to the other side of the map but
also get me up where are you Dave there
you go run run don't shoot just
run this not oh God get my do are you
dead no don't do this to me get the dog
tag don't do this to me son of a [__] T
is all on you no I'm still alive okay
get my dog tag then please first of all
just get the dog tag though
the assumption that I had died I was
trying to scroll and it wouldn't
work you're not even using cover oh I'm
down tomor where are you I'm a little
busy run past him he can't he can't
turn wave 20 failed damn I didn't get a
single
kill well as it usually happens I think
we fought viant though wave 20 is
respectable yeah that was good that was
all right that was fun GG Locus you win
this time swarm swarm GG
swarm and if you enjoyed this video make
sure you hit the like button subscribe
to gamesport for more ideas playing
video games okay thanks bye say bye
everyone bye everyone
bye